all right so this time I'm going to try
the different visually so I want to
understand this guy and then I want to
understand this guy and see how they
interact I want to know where this is
less than this that's another way of
saying on the graph when is this below
this okay so that's that's how I'm
translating okay getting skates on
all right let's draw this thing if I
want to understand this okay the first
thing I'm going to do is think about it
without absolute value signs the reason
why is because actually very easy if you
go this simple
what was this I don't know let's make
something up this is like 1 minus x
squared ok I moved it up one unit and
it's a downward facing parabola okay so
if I now say hey what's the absolute
value of that all you have to do is say
when this graph is positive
you're leaving alone absolute value
doesn't touch things when they're
positive but when it's negative you put
a minus sign up well visually that means
you flip it upside down okay so that's
the shape you're going to get that green
one is the absolute value of 1 minus x
squared so so the black one is just
regular one minus x squared and one of
the reasons why doing a visual is so is
so easy is because if you know what the
regular graph looks like all you have to
do is take the negative bits and just
come up the top so that's why you see
this kind of awkward reflection on the
edges ok when the same thing over here
I want to understand what does this look
like ok so help me out a little bit if I
say y equals x plus 1 or X how can I
start to draw this
okay if I start to draw I know that x
equals zero is a vertical asymptote
because if it blows up there okay so I'm
just gonna put some dots there so it's
not going to be equal to that y equals x
looks like this doesn't it
okay so I'll just supposed to put that
through like that and why cuz one on X
looks like this do you agree okay now
when you look at this I want to add
these two things together won't it atom
together
okay so tell me for example where is it
these graphs intersect where did they
hit each other when they collide this is
why X I think the place where they have
the exact same value is X is equal to 1
June is that because X is equal 1 X
equal 1 on 1 that's 5 0 so this is 1
foot both great okay but remember I'm
adding the graphs together yeah so
what's one plus one it's two so one plus
one is two okay I can work that what the
shape of this thing is going to look
like in much the same way have a look at
what's happening over here as I moved to
the right this graph is going up but
this graph is becoming 0 do you notice
that yeah so therefore I'll be like it's
this Plus this and then this Plus this
and I'm adding this value to gets little
in order to learn literally all the way
off to infinity okay
so therefore what's gonna happen is I'm
going to get closer and closer and
closer to this line because I'm adding
smaller and smaller numbers is that ok
in the same way how long to the left do
you see that this guy became becomes
literally through Midler and this guy
takes off so I'm gonna do the same thing
up here okay so if I join the dots
that's the shape like it okay which is a
little bit weird but that's what adding
this and this tells me okay now at the
moment this looks a bit unfamiliar
because you haven't really had to graph
things like this very much yet you will
and you can't avoid it it's part of the
cost and so even though it's a little
unfamiliar at the moment you you're
gonna have to deal with that and as
opposed to this this gets simpler the
longer you deal with it the more you
become familiar with it whereas this it
never become simpler like even for
someone to dealing with with it for
years I have to just crunch through
lines and lines and lines of algebra
every single line of which is another
opportunity to say I put a minus sign in
the wrong spot or I multiplied by the
wrong thing and then a simple numerical
error screws you up all the way okay I'm
gonna reverse it you're going to get the
same shape over here but backwards like
that so this is this graph hmm now
remember when I turned over here and I
said here's a graph and then check
absolute value sign around it what
effect did that have to be really do you
ever up and down what that did it took
all these negative parts and it moved in
so stop do you remember that so have a
look at my graph over here I'm gonna get
rid of all these constructions now I
just added these in so I could get known
to your father to convoy which are the
negative parts of this crap it's just
this part isn't it so it's going to go
up the top
go on ok so that's what this graph this
graph looks like I'm done I know it
looks a bit strange but that's it so now
I want to know when is that that thing
less then 2 X okay now I just draw two
back so I'm asking when is this below
this do you see yeah okay now this is
what I meant by I'm gonna enter in
directly the question set explain why X
must be greater than zero here's why how
I look at the whole X is less than zero
part do you see this green thing is
never going to be below this black thing
it's not possible because the green
thing is always positive the black thing
is always negative so this is never
gonna like there's no climb that's going
to be like whoops I'm going to go down
here and and fly underneath this black
line it'll never happen so I can say hey
look from this graph clearly all of this
negative that's all positive so I can
ignore that part okay
the real answer is gonna be somewhere
over here okay so how do I find out what
that answer will be we'll remember I
said to you here if you want to find out
where there's an inequality star you can
just turn it into an equation and then
just solve that that's all you have to
do well I did that over here so I put in
black okay so I found where did these
two graphs intersect each other it'll be
plus and minus one okay now hold on a
second only one of those values actually
works right which one is it
it's gonna be this guy here that has to
be plus one because remember we just
decided X can't be negative right
because we lose of the graph and we're
like I'm gonna get nothing from over
there so that's useless to me
so therefore this guy here must be x
equals one that must be the value that's
where they intersect that's where my
inequality starts
do I want to put this side on this side
I want when the curvy thing is beneath
the straight line where is that this is
quick everything or any of the straight
line yeah
so do you see that these parts over here
are good these curly bits are beneath
the straight line these parts are not
these cabinets are above the straight
line that's no good to me I don't want
those I only want these ones okay so
this is x equals 1 and I'm going to the
right to the right
that's the inequality X is greater than
1 note how much abroad no case is
required okay
so drawing takes some time but that kind
of comes with practice and you'll start
to recognize shapes like this is um the
lion's share at the time we took to work
this thing out we're just to work out
what this thing looks like but now that
you've seen this like you're going to
see more of these and the pattern is
much the same okay
so if you draw them can you draw any
certain qualities you can at least go
ahead right oh this will always be the
case for example come out look at this
one right see how I've got a picture now
it's really easy there well I could
solve this for the same set of
inequalities I could do this
when is it greater than 2x okay so I can
say well this is / 2x on you right and
then I say well which parts are above
that line and I'll just say all this
part is there's going to be a part over
here where this guy takes over like that
because it will keep going gets deeper
so I find this value and then go to the
left and then find this value and go to
the right and there's your in quality
okay so working out the graph takes time
but number one it's a skill that must be
developed and number two like it's a
hundred
and going through multiple different is
it that one yeah that's fine it's in
cases are hot I try to avoid them
wherever I possibly can for that exact
reason okay yeah yeah
Russell just find your before you dash
off let me just say one more thing I can
directly answer without going ahead and
solving it you know there's a potty talk
about why XSP been easier I'll see you
in period four so they want to say why
is this the case right so you know it's
not X is greater than one
yeah well X has to be positive no love
yeah like everything greater than one is
also a positive number
okay so why is this true the reason I
drew the graph is because I knew and had
to solve the thing and that's the
quickest way but if all I had to answer
was that if that was the whole question
and then I actually care about the
proper solution he's the way I would
argue it this thing by definition must
be positive right because it's absolute
value okay now if you've got a positive
thing and then you've got two x well two
x is a very simple graph 2 X looks like
that now if this is going to be positive
all of y equals 2x or the two x is going
to be negative over there so therefore
you'll never get solutions over here and
absolute value will never
there because by definition is positive
so a positive thing can never be less
than that if that's negative and that is
negative when X is 2 X is negative when
X is negative okay so you can see that's
a quicker way to answer their question
but if they then say okay now solve it
so it didn't save me that much time to
do that add to that question on its own
independently